distinguished colleagues
in recent days
the ukrainian issue
has uh
made headlines global headlines and has
now
been given pride of place at the u.n
security council and now the general
assembly at the same time
russian actions are being distorted
and thwarted
and there is a number of incredible
fakes is staggering with the use uh with
the media outlets and social networks
proliferating uh these lies for this
reason today i wish to focus on the real
reasons for the crisis that has emerged
and its possible consequences i wish to
emphasize the following the root for the
current crisis lies in the actions of
ukraine itself for many years it
sabotaged and flouted its direct
obligations under the min package of
measures
to the ongoing the persistent aggressive
actions that undertaken by the ukrainian
regime the ukrainian authorities
which has
of late been actively
uh armed and incited by a number of
states
were
under the misconception that with the
uh the the indulgence of western patrons
and sponsors they would be able to
address the issues and bus militarily it
is difficult otherwise it would be
difficult to explain the ongoing
intensification of shelling and sabotage
acts on the territory of the republics
which i mentioned the people of donbass
and lugan's
continued to have to take shelter in
basements uh there
was a flood of refugees entering the
russian federation and the yet still the
nature of the ukrainian armed forces
operation did not change and yet western
partners did not wish uh turned a blind
eye to this and they merely echoed
ukrainian tall tales about
the
allegations that dunbas people were
shelling on themselves
the worsening uh suffering of the
residents of donbass is something that
has
left
western sponsors unmoved in recent years
this discussion at the security council
general assembly there was no empathy
whatsoever no compassion for the people
of dunbas and lugansk it seems that
these four million people simply don't
exist for them and as a result the
ongoing threats targeting the people of
lpr and dpr
given the lack of prospects for
addressing the problems in the area
under the minsk operations due to the
failure to fulfillment the russian
president took a decision for a special
military special military operation to
be carried out and then bus occupation
of ukraine is not part of this of these
plans the goal of the special operation
is to protect the people who for eight
years were subject to torment and
guinness and genocide by the kia regime
to that end
there is
there's a need to demilitarize and
denazify ukraine
further will strive to hold accountable
those who carried out countless brutal
crimes against the people uh the
residents
uh including uh residents of the russian
federation this decision was taken in
line with article 51 of the united
nations charter with a sanction of the
federation council of the russian
federation
in pursuant of the agreement on
friendship cooperation with dpr and lpr
i wish to recall further that the
principal sovereignty and territorial
eternity of states
something which we are being accused of
breaching vis-a-vis ukraine the
declaration of principles of
international law on friendly relations
between peoples was adopted in 1970
and it needs to be unstintingly complied
with with respect to states i quote
complying in
conducting themselves in compliance with
the principle of equal rights and
self-determination of peoples as
described above and thus possessed of a
government representing the whole people
belonging to the territory without
distinction as to race creed or color
end of quote
today's government of ukraine is no such
government
moreover during the special military
operation russia has been exercising its
right to self-defense from a regime that
has been striving to
gain access to nuclear weapons